it was so sweet watching those episodes
because everybody was like do we go out
without mic like what do we do without
him like everybody just was like they're
so weird like watching those episodes
for you I was watching those episodes in
prison the ones that I was not in did
they set that up for you no no they
actually liked me in prison so I was
really able to sort of watch it and it
was my wedding season so I had a lot to
sort of like look forward to and it was
such a beautiful wedding and you know
their daughters walk down the aisle so I
was it was really in my fields for the
eight months and excited to you know
reunite obviously like the prison had a
Jersey Shore party everything yeah they
did they did was the name of that room
that you always went to with the TV that
is the TV room you need a permission to
actually watch like you know the show
that you like so luckily they liked me
in there and I was able to watch Jersey
Shore every Thursday night even while in
prison Wow were you like famous in there
like where people are like it's the
search I want to work out with you you
know what it was pretty cool I mean I
would say you don't ever get a hundred
percent approval rate but I was lucky
that they liked me in there they liked
them you're in comeback mode yeah what
does this look like going forward into
the the back half of the season well for
me I just wanted to reunite my friends
and I worked very hard for that eight
months to sort of lose the weights
continue to remain sober in Sodor Sodor
reunited my friends so yeah I was living
by that mantra every day the comeback is
greater than setback and we documented
that and you'll see that on this season
I gotta say like the the muscles are
here there are presents yeah you gotta
thank God for that Prison bid right he
ripped his pants while sitting Nicole I
gotta ask cuz seeing you know how much
everybody missed Mike
how does Jersey Shore go forward without
you yeah Nicole yeah listen Nicole show
we're all a part of this together
parties here needs to be a part of it
happening I just feel like you know
people move on sometimes and having
three kids and leaving and doing all of
it it's just really really hard for me
and I don't and I've said this before
but like I don't want to leave my kids
and go into like a toxic environment
where there's drama and I'm upset all
the time you know what I mean I just
can't do that so just had to make a move
so you're saying there's a chance
yeah I love you guys yeah she may come
in like maybe hopefully she'll make some
visitation yeah so how are you guys
feeling about I slept next to her here
10 years so my meatball this whole
season that's coming up Nicole's a part
of it cuz we got him did already she
made the decision after the season
wrapped because what the viewers are
gonna be is it is really dramatic yeah
there's more to her leaving than just
the kids yeah yes I make the decision in
life and Dean and I are going through
the same emotions where it's like we're
gonna leave our families we're gonna
leave our children and when you go into
a workplace where it's just like oh like
we don't get us wrong we love our
production and we love majority of our
cast mates but then there are times when
like you know why am i leaving my family
yeah like just scream fight and argue
all the time Abel is there anything
you're like dreading having to rewatch
that you you know is coming up bad times
and that's what makes us so great
because you're really gonna get
something genuine authentic and when you
put us all together we really have an
awesome dynamic and that's why we've
been around for 10 years yeah like we
said like we love everyone we work with
for the majority so no but I'm just
saying like like I don't we it is very
hard leaving our kids so like won't do
to try to be politically correct but you
know like her I don't want to go into a
situation where I'm leaving my child and
I'm having
fight with people like that's I don't
like fighting to begin with I'm not that
type of person I would never do anything
to hurt anybody so when I'm portrayed
certain ways for no reason I don't want
to be in that situation so we're gonna
have to see you know what is yeah how
this season plays out and you know if we
continue what its gonna be like
I'm calling this season like the part
two of this season the redemption
because there was so much drama and the
first one and I was seen in a certain
light which I didn't really care for
that I'm hoping as the new season airs
like it shows it I always ask for like
just be transparent and be real mm-hmm
and it's hard sometimes for production
to get that in like 42 minutes an
episode because there's so much that
goes on so all I asked was like I don't
want favoritism I just wanted to play
out real and there'll always be haters
and fans that like wanted to see you
fail like as mom's it's very hard to be
like a working mom and being judged for
things that might be like misconstrued
wrong like where's your scene in like a
different light that didn't play out
like that in real time
is there something specifically that
played out the first half of the season
they like that your drama Point Pleasant
and you weren't there I think so it's
like Point Pleasant and and the first
season and just like how we're like
screaming and it just was so dramatic
and because of that I ended up on TMZ
and it was like portrayed wrong it's
literally like what you said the
producers don't have enough time to
actually do the whole you know the
bickering the whole fight the whole
story
yeah they have to cut it down to the
most dramatic parts and sometimes it's
not the greatest parts this season is
definitely going to be a situation it's
fire yeah good stuff very good yeah Mike
coming home we have a really fun
bachelorette party for Angelina your
divorce party we have a lot of
celebrations yeah so well Jenni I was I
was lurking on the insta you and Zach
look extremely happy Manhattan sunsets
things kind of look like you guys hit
like a speed bump towards the end of the
first half of the season when you bring
an outsider and that's like never better
hey that's young that looks up to a lot
of my cast members that they're my best
friends so I don't look as Mike as a
situation a Nicola Snooki and Deena is
yo Deena
so I forget that that's intimidating for
someone to come in and you know lines
are cross and the innocence can be taken
away because then you're in front of
millions of people but we're great right
now we take we're taking it slow
happened on the last season and I just
hope that like with this new one coming
up that it can become like full circle
and everybody moves on and you know the
dramas left yes like the thing is like
most of us we portray ourselves as we
really are on the show and we put on a
good show that way some other people put
on a show for the show so we are at the
10th anniversary of the show you guys
you know in the first iteration or just
living in this house drink and going out
having a good time this time around it's
way more real is is it harder now to do
the show or was it harder than when
you're just young it's definitely hard I
mean it's really hard to leave our kids
you know like it's so hard and I
remember back then the basic heartache
is different oh no cell phone no
internet no TV in like 50 days straight
oh man yeah yeah I think it was hard
about like I felt like like back then it
was like you didn't have social media
wasn't yeah also for me it was easier
back then cuz I would just get drunk and
I'd be like you know screw it it's a
month of my life I'm not like I have
nothing at home maybe I'd Chris but he
got it like he understood I would he
would come visit me like now it's like I
can't be a belief for my kid for like
two days you know that's hard for me so
you know it's just it's more difficult
now thank you - nice it's happening it's
happening ooh
[Music]